foreign
kicks us off in Chicago Sebastian
welcome to the show
hey y'all how are you doing today we're
doing great how can we help
yeah so um I've been kind of floundering
around trying to figure out what to do
with my life and I think I boiled it
down to like a fundamental question uh
do I do something for a cause that I can
get behind but I don't really enjoy the
daily work of or do I do something that
I enjoy uh the work of you know daily
but I would have difficulty getting
behind the purpose of and you know I'm
generally a purpose-driven person so I I
kind of I think I would struggle with
doing just a job I merely enjoy but
wouldn't really be able to get behind
and then the last few days though I have
kind of like maybe narrowed it down to
something that I can get behind both uh
but I've also like changed my mind a lot
so I don't know if that's uh certain
yeah well if if there's one thing I'm
certain of it's you or uncertain my
friend and thank you yeah it's okay it's
okay we're going to help you with that
so I want to know this idea where you
say you could do both because that's
what I teach and you've created a false
choice
do something that the work itself I
enjoy but the results of the work don't
connect to my values or do something
where the values the results of the work
connect but I don't enjoy the work
that's a false choice I actually teach
that we as humans are on purpose doing
what we were created to do when we use
what we do best
to do work we love
to produce results that matter to us so
what's this third idea this idea you've
been kicking around where you think you
can do both
do the work you love and connect to the
results what is it
yeah it'd be like a university professor
of government philosophy and economics
okay tell us why that would be work that
you love focus on the work itself
okay uh like the the daily in and out
yeah what about that job as being a
professor of government would be work
that you love
uh first of all I love teaching people
things it's something I'm passionate
about I'm also uh phenomenal at studying
that's what I did throughout my own
University career so I'd also have the
opportunity to study myself and then
teach others and engage them um in a in
a way that would really challenge them
to think like I could go in and teach
something like math which is probably
what I enjoy the most but but it's not
something that I could really like get
behind but something with government and
economics uh you have the opportunity to
shape uh young minds and challenge
others to think about the way that
Society is constructed think away think
about the way that governments are set
up and ask the question is like is this
is what we're doing the best way uh for
the people okay and that's especially
because I've seen and I've been to other
countries where it's just a mess you
know okay so you answered my next
question which is what results what are
the values that that position would
allow you to connect with and you just
went ahead and answered that so if you
look at what I just said to you when you
use it you do best to do work you love
to produce results that matter you
you're on fire you're on purpose and you
you experience extreme fulfillment and
so those three elements are Talent
passion and Mission
I'm using my talent to perform my
passion to accomplish my mission does
that make sense to you
using my talent
um to perform my passion it's a yes or
no question I'm going to say it again
Dan it's as simple as it gets my young
friend who wants to teach if I use my
talent to perform my passion to
accomplish my mission does that make
sense to you
that makes sense all right then does the
college professor of government and
economics allow you to do that yes or no
and this is something that's like I I
think so we're so close what do you mean
you think so what do you mean you think
so
no you you no no
what now here's where the problem comes
in
your thinking instead of feeling
I'm not saying that's the only job for
you where you can do that but if we look
at college professor of government
economics we have to run it through that
grid
it doesn't mean it's the only job for
you but it allows you to go could I do
that well would I enjoy it and would it
produce results that mattered me what's
the answer yes or no
I guess it's the best thing that I've
come across so far you know the answer
is yes or no would that job allow you to
fulfill I'm not saying you got to choose
it I'm saying would it meet the
requirement yes or no
the answer is yes the answer is yes just
say yes for a second then I'm going to
lead you further yes or no sure yes all
right now now what we have to do is we
say okay that one seems to check all the
boxes but I'm gonna go do the work of
clarifying and verifying and here's what
that means you need to actually spend
some time with a college professor
coffee lunch talk to them learn
everything about the ins and outs of
that job The Good The Bad George the
ugly and when you do that Sebastian that
will then allow you to go ding ding ding
or does that make sense yes or no
that makes sense all right see now we're
not so locked up right
yeah you don't have to get off this
phone call and choose college professor
but I gave you a process by which you
can know with tremendous Clarity and
confidence that this is what I want to
do that's been your jam you you've been
all stuck on uncertainty and I just gave
you a process so go spend time with
college professors and if it's a no then
we keep using that purpose statement
plan let's give him by the way the get
clear assessment hang on the line
Sebastian we're going to give you a tool
that's going to give you a great
high-level job description it's called
the get clear assessment